I want to thank the organizers it's been
enjoyable conference so far hopefully I
don't ruin it
yeah but I'm looking forward to other
people's talks as well so what I'm going
to talk about is something that I'm very
passionate about which is trying to
understand how we can make use of the
various kinds of high-throughput data
that are increasingly available unlike
my pointer which is no longer available
now here it is No all right well I'll
point a lot various kinds of
high-throughput data to understand and
have an impact on human health and so
just to clarify some of the jargon right
so obviously after the high-throughput
sequencing of the genome file just
realized that they could use the same
technology to interrogate many other
kinds of molecules so after the genome
we have the transcriptome all the mRNAs
that and other RNAs that are expressed
in the cell and then the epigenome which
is measurements of protein DNA
interactions in which regulatory regions
are functional under which conditions
but that's blood to motivation to maybe
we can measure everything in the cell
and we're not quite there yet but we're
definitely on our way so the proteome is
measurements of all the proteins yeah I
must have lost it or something
they had it here Oh floor thank you
there we go so the proteome is measure
old proteins using mass spec which is a
different technology but the motivation
is the same can we have a comprehensive
catalogue of all the molecules
themselves and how they change in
response to different perturbations
we're talking today a quite a bit about
the metabolome which is small molecules
and that's used generically to cover
metabolites lipids many other kinds of
molecules as well I don't think this one
got an ohm but screening data right so
screen ohm perhaps but all the genetic
perturbations that one can do to cell
whether it's crispr RNA I si RNAs or
traditional knockouts in yeast so look
at chemical perturbations as well to see
how the phenotype is affected and then
the interact ohm is the set of all
protein protein interactions and so the
question is whether all these data have
really
help us understand and treat disease and
so what I think they've done so far is
help us understand basic biology the
amount that we've learned about
transcription in the last decade is
probably more than everything since
manole Jacobi combined so it's really
been amazing the microbiome was not
something people really thought about
much but all the microbe is that are
inhabiting us and contributing
positively or negatively to our health
proteomics has told us a lot about
signaling that we didn't know about
before when you think about moving
closer and closer to human health I
think the big impact has been on tumor
classification telling us the subtypes
of tumors with fine detail hasn't really
led to any new therapies and I'm willing
to be challenged on that but I'm not
aware of any therapy that we could
really say you've got with omics that
you could not have gotten in other ways
there are some places where omics agrees
with what a histology would tell you but
beyond that so so what I'm interested is
whether we can go beyond just collecting
these data and understanding the basic
biology which is important in and of
itself and move on to actually finding
points of intervention in the cell to
develop new therapeutics and so the
outline of today's talk will be first
I'd like to give an extremely quick
motivation of what we're doing and the
methods I spoke here in August at the
beginning of of this series of workshops
and so I want to go through this quickly
enough so those of you were here don't
start reading your email but slowly
enough for those of who were not can
actually follow what's going on so
hopefully I hit the right balance if I
don't look confused and I'll or I look
forward and I'll try to speed up or slow
down as appropriate and then I'd like to
show you how we've been advancing these
methods now to focus on metabolomics and
the potential the metabolomics have for
understanding a wide range of diseases
which were not necessarily thought of as
being metabolic in nature all right so
this was probably the first 15 minutes
the last talk hopefully I can do it a
lot more quickly so we apply these omics
technologies to our biological system of
interest and now what are you going to
do with those data so the typical thing
one does is one goes back to gene
ontology which we talked about yesterday
or other hand annotated or maybe
automatic like the stuff Trey was
talking about pathway annotations and
try to see to what extent do the data
that I've
in this condition relate to some known
pathway and that has value but as I
showed in the previous talk it actually
captures a fairly very small fraction of
all the biological change so in systems
where we know what's going on allegedly
and we carry out of perturbation and we
match it up with the databases about 15%
of the signal is actually in the
annotated pathway now the other stuff is
actually happening and it's relevant to
that pathway but someone has to draw a
circle around where the pathway ends
right and that's very important for
categorization but it doesn't mean that
the stuff that's outside of that circle
as the signal continues to propagate is
irrelevant to that biological process so
we need ways of capturing all of that
and understanding it in the context of
our diseases so that's one of the first
challenges we can't just plug our data
into annotated pathways a second kind of
approach is when you do more than one
kind of experiment on the same
biological system an SD who's was my
postdoc of time and he's here today and
Lowry was also posting live and time
really did a deep dive into this using
yeast data and what they showed was that
when you apply more than one of these
ohmic technologies to the same system
you get typically less overlap than you
would expect by chance among the results
right and so what does that mean so the
the nervous approach would be oh my gosh
our assays are terrible that's why
there's no overlap but in fact what she
showed quite elegantly is that these
different assays are asking different
questions they're answering different
questions and so if you take everything
as the answering the same question you
don't see much overlap you feel upset
but actually if you realize that there
are different kinds of information that
you get out of different omics
then you can try to design an approach
that actually captures those differences
so when people talk about data
integration in omics they often mean
doing one of these fun diagrams and
taking the overlap but in fact that's
exactly the wrong approach because all
the stuff you're leaving out is what's
really interesting okay and then the
last point I want to make on this
challenges is what do you do with all
the mRNA data they're out there so I
haven't checked the databases recently
but a few years ago they were
approaching about a million gene
expression data sets and the various G
Gia
go geodatabase and the european one so
we've got a lot of mRNA data and the
intuitive thing that everyone in the
field felt was the right thing to do was
to use this as a proxy for protein
levels that made sense until we could
actually measure protein levels in a
high-throughput way and then we
discovered that actually the two are
very poorly correlated so what are we
going to do with all that mRNA data if
it's a bad proxy for protein levels so
those are the motivations for our
approach so the approach that we take is
imagine you've got some biological
process and you're reading it out with
these different assays and I've colored
molecules based on what acid is
detecting them and there'll be
biological processes that are not
annotated correctly in the databases
that consists of some molecules detected
by one assay and some Alec is detected
by another and a lot of molecules that
were detected by any assay so you want
to recapture all of these biological
processes de novo without having
recourse to the databases and Vout
needing any single assay to give us all
the right answers and if we do this well
then we can capture a lot of molecules
that were invisible to the different
assays so that's the motivation so how
do we go about doing this so with the
mRNA data we said we can't use them as a
proxy for protein levels so what are
they a good proxy for well there are
pretty good proxy for transcription
they're not perfect because we're not
measuring degradation rates and so on
but we can use the mRNA data as evidence
that some transcriptional regulator
turned on or off those genes and so
we're going to use epigenomic data and
sequence analysis to try to identify
those DNA binding proteins and then
we're going to try to find what were the
signaling pathways that activated those
transcription factors and so we can do
that by incorporating different kinds of
data say it's date about which proteins
are phosphorylated from a mass spec
experiment or from a high-throughput
screen which ones are drug targets that
affect the cells in that particular
condition so we've got these other
molecules that may be in the same
pathway and we want to try to figure out
how they're connected and here we turn
to the interactome that giant compendium
of all physical in this case protein
protein interactions we try to find the
connections so that's the general
motivation now when we actually do this
and you might have some sense of the
some yesterday stalks because of the
smallworld properties of the network
it's very easy to connect almost
anything to almost anything else and so
very rapidly you've turned a problem
small problem that he didn't understand
into a large problem that you don't
understand right and you get one of
these hair balls and so we need to
figure out how to get rid of the hair
ball and so there many different
approaches the one that we are quite
fond of is this thing called a prize
collecting steiner forest approach and
this i'll just try to again explain very
quickly because i went through in great
detail the last time I was here the idea
is that we have some molecules in our
interactome this is a tiny piece of that
hair Bowl which we've experimentally
detected is changing maybe through
foster proteomics those have say the
yellow color we've got these
transcription factors that are triangles
that we detected by analyzing the mRNA
data and trying to go upstream and then
there are a lot of molecules that we
don't know anything about in gray and
all these interactive interactions which
are the lines and we're trying to ask
the algorithm to find some sub Network
here that is highly implicated as being
relevant to the disease so in addition
to knowing how much information we have
about each node whether it's changing or
not we also know a lot about the edges
because these databases of interactions
allow us to go back and understand the
reliability of the edges so we can
weight each edge by its reliability and
so we sign an edge cost based on the
reliability of an edge if you're
unreliable you cost a lot if you're
reliable you're cheap and we assign a
price to each node based on our
conference that's changing the
biological system and then we try to
optimize this equation which says try to
leave behind as few prizes as possible
gather as many prizes as you can into
the network but every time you add a
prize when you add the edge you have to
pay a cost for that edge and that
trade-off then which is determined by
this one parameter allows you to
determine the size of the final network
and so when the algorithms trying to
decide whether to include this node
it'll get the prize if includes it but I
have to pay all these edge costs at the
same time so that's the trade-off and by
optimizing this problem then you can get
smaller or larger networks that you
believe are more relevant to your
disease so in the interest of time I can
go through how you solve this but I'm
having to talk people in discussion
afterwards about how to do that
so that was the very very fast overview
of the method now I'm going to tell you
about how we think about this
incorporating new kinds of data and
metabolomics in particular so this is
work done by two graduate students in my
lab and they Soltis and Leila pet Hoshi
Anthony is working primarily untargeted
metabolomics and Layla on untargeted so
what's the difference here so a lot of
assays you can measure a couple of
hundred metabolites and you know when
you do the assay that measuring say ATP
or measuring a particular phospholipid
that's what I'm we talked about first
but I'm sorry metabolomics is much much
broader than that you can measure tens
of thousands of things but typically all
you find out is the mass of those
molecules you don't know exactly what
they are some of these slightly
different approaches for those two
different kinds of data okay so we've
got these metabolites well first talk
about ones where we know the identity we
know that particular sphingolipid is
changing in our assay or a particular
ATP is changing in our assay and how
we're going to incorporate this into
this approach so hopefully the approach
the idea is fairly simple we just need
to be able to find edges that represent
the physical associations of those
metabolites with proteins and so for
that purpose we took a protein protein
interaction database and added to it
protein small molecule interactions so
our final combined Network has over a
million edges it's got over 40,000 nodes
and it represents a fairly good fraction
of what's known today about all
different kinds of molecular
interactions inside cells again a niche
was the time not going to go through the
tails of this there are a lot of
subtleties as to how you weight this
maybe we didn't do this the best
possible way I'd be good in the
discussion to hear people's comments but
we chose a particular way of weighting
these various kinds of databases but
then importantly we test our results to
see how sensitive they are to those
choices so we only report results that
are robust to various choices that we
make and how to combine these interact
zones the point I'd like to linger on a
little bit more and this again was
motivated by stuff that we talked about
yesterday
what's up to do with high degree nodes
in these interactions so these are
histograms showing the number of nodes
with a particular degree and notice the
log scales so the protein-protein
interact them there are a few proteins
that have a degree distribution of over
a hundred but the protein metabolites
rack unit actually is quite worse there
are some nodes that have a degree of
over 10,000 so if I've got these nodes
in my network that are connected to
10,000 things think of say calcium
something like that right and in the
protein interact oh maybe think about
p53 molecules that are either highly
studied or really are ubiquitously
interacting with many things they will
allow me to connect almost anything I
measured almost anything else so what am
I going to do about that if I put those
into my network then they're gonna show
up in every single Network I generate
and they're gonna trivially basically
short-circuit my network on the other
hand if I leave them out right I'm
throwing away real biology I want p53 to
show up in my cancer data I just don't
want to show up in every single data set
so approach that we took - this was to
go back to the idea that we have these
prizes that we can associate with notes
for which we think we have evidence that
they are part of our biological system
just one second I'll come to you in a
second and we can also then put a prize
in the negative sense we can give a
negative prize indicates we don't
believe something is relevant to our
biological system and by having both
positive prizes this data was changing
my system and negative prize don't
include this high degree note unless
you're certain about it right then it
allows the algorithm to trade it off and
so the negative prize that we give is
based on the degree of a node that's
negative times some constant times of
the degree if it's a protein times the
degrees squared if it's a metabolite yes
there's a question there's a point now
there's again a new parameter they have
to introduce them this has to be chosen
arbitrarily at some level I mean we try
to use various kinds of validation but
we assign this based on the degree
distribution exactly we varied the
numbers see how stable our results are
to various parameter choices so there'll
be regimes in which you tend to get
fairly similar results over a broad
range of parameters those the networks
that we want to focus on so this
approach then allows the algorithm to
include p53 or calcium when it's really
relevant but not be forced to include it
just as a shortest path between
everything to avoid it's
short-circuiting our network so I think
this is an important aspect an advantage
of using this formulation although there
are obviously other ways you could
approach this as well all right so to
give you an example of how this works
I'll show you the work that Anthony's
been doing on insulin resistance this is
obviously a major problem in the
developed world that's increasing a
problem in the developing world
insulin resistance one of the first
steps towards type-2 diabetes which is
typically caused by overeating and so we
have a mouse model of this where we put
mice on one of two diets they can eat as
much as they want of either the normal
child that mice and laboratories get or
a high-fat diet if you put them on the
high-fat diet they get as you might
imagine fat and when they get fat they
get insulin resistant interestingly not
all mice strains have the same outcome
but anyway the standard laboratory Mouse
gets found in these high-fat diets and
becomes insulin resistance and so
working together with Roger Davis and
UMass Medical and Jared Marto at Harvard
Medical School
we collected many different kinds of
omec data on the livers of these mice
after they've gotten fat and insulin
resistant so in my lab we collected RNA
seek data we also did chips take for
various protein DNA interactions Jared
did protein analysis by mass spec and we
used metabolize
are gated metabolomic data okay so what
do you see when you look at these data
so these data have all the challenges
that we expected when we analyzed this
problem so here I'm showing you mRNA
data and protein level data for each
gene so for each gene is a row and then
it shows you the encoded mRNA in the
coded protein and it's colored in red if
it's increase in the high fat diet and
blue if it's decreased I've had died and
you can see that there's no correlation
between the two you can make this single
a little bit better if you focus if you
remove all the white rose basically and
focus on those things that are changing
in both the MRA level and the protein
level but again your correlation comes
out to about point four which is what
typically people see to get better than
this you really need to do experiments
and systems where you can measure
degradation rates and synthesis rates
and that's not applicable at all here so
it's not surprising but it also means
there's no point in trying to use the
mRNA as proxies for proteins as we
described before
so instead remember what we're going to
do with mRNA data is we're gonna use it
as a proxy for transcriptional changes
we're gonna try to identify denovo what
the transcription factors were and here
we take advantage of the fact that we
measured using chip seek various histone
marks so if these vertical lines
indicate places where there
big changes in the histone data we
suspect that there's some set of
transcription factors that are sitting
there so we look for these regions near
their changes in the histone data and we
scan them for the motifs we have a large
library motif so we get a bunch of
motifs now not all these motifs are
gonna be right so we use a simple
univariate regression approach to try to
figure out which transcription factors
have the biggest impact on gene
expression so transcription factor motif
has to be present in these regions near
the chromatin changes and it's strength
of the motif has to increase as genes
have a stronger motif they have to have
a bigger effect on transcription whether
that's an I in this case going up with
transcription or going down and again
I'd be happy to talk with evil about the
details afterwards so when we capture a
number of known transcription factors
but a lot of unknowns as well and then
we can put those into this prize
clicking Steiner forest approach I
renamed prize flipping Steiner force
which I can barely pronounce into omics
integrator hopefully it's also a little
easier to remember so we plug all these
different data that we collected in our
collaborators collected into omics
integrator what do we get out we get out
of network and we can then cluster that
Network and see whether there are
functionally cohere in modules whether
we discover new proteins that are
associated with insulin resistance with
diabetes so one of the challenges
interpreting these networks so you get
hundreds of nodes some of them were
implicated directly in your data you
measure the protein was changing but in
this case about 450 465 of these
proteins were not previously detected
we're not directly detecting in our
experiments so there these hid nodes are
in the prize flicking Steiner fourths
approach that comes sometimes called
Steiner nodes so all the things in white
are these nodes that for which I sorry
so so we have these hidden nodes we want
to try to figure out if they've been
previously associated the disease so we
used a database called dis gene net
which uses natural language processing
and also some curation to try to
associate genes with the disease to try
to systematically figure out how many of
these things in our network are actually
previously associated with either
diabetes insulin resistance or obesity
and we can see that a fairly large
fraction of all the proteins that we're
identifying had not previously been
associated with the disease
now we're not gonna try to go through
systematically and try to study 500
novel proteins so instead we try to look
at these functionally coherent subunits
sub networks and try it out well
look at these something besides see if
they're functioning coherent and see if
we can learn something about insulin
resistance yeah we didn't look for the
significance is primarily tool for us to
try to decide what to focus on further
so it may or may not be significant but
when you're looking at these networks
you don't want to spend all your time
studying something that's already well
characterizing disease and I'm not such
an expert on insulin resistance to be
able to say ah yes you know Excel 23
that's well characterized yeah I should
we should do it we should do the hyper
geometric distribution I just don't know
the answer
Spiner forest is their defense in the
semantics except if the weights between
the proteins and the small molecules
because I'm thinking about situation
where you have a chain frequently
previously you have the chain of rotting
that you could be perfect as a signaling
that's right so the semantics here is
entirely just that an edge represents of
physical associations so when we have
multiple substrates of an enzyme
they'll all be connected by edges to
that enzyme right and then depending how
the network structure comes out it might
not be easily easy to reconstruct what
that was in terms of metabolite abala
crosses I'll show you an example of that
actually so here's a sub Network where
again the things that have color red or
blue are things that are changing in
high-fat diet or not in the normal diet
these diamond shapes are metabolites the
circles are proteins gray things were
then anodes that were added by the
algorithm and it's not obvious that
there's an enzymatic pathway here so one
has to then do some work to try to
figure out what's going on now in this
particular case many many of the
molecules here are involved in bile acid
metabolism so we had some reason to
think that something was going on with
bile acid metabolism but it turns out
that two of these are actually
transporters for bile acid and so this
lettuce hypothesis that wasn't
necessarily could be but it wasn't
necessarily a problem with the
metabolism bias it might be a problem
with the transport of bile acid and so
actually went back to these livers and
actually able to show that there's a lot
of leakage of bile acid into the liver
so again the semantics is purely
interactions and in the interpretation
that requires other kinds of approaches
and I'll come back to that point at the
very end so we did a number of other
kinds of that of tests here hypotheses
that emerge from the networks that we
were then able to test by going back to
the histology of these liver samples we
do detect changes in the paddock
architecture and changes in apoptosis
and so on
five minutes all right so I will
probably cut through a bunch of slides
here but I also want to mention
so that'll previous work was all in
cases where we knew what the metabolite
was that was changing and so we could
put a node in the network but in most of
the metabolites are not detectable by
that assay so rather they're technical
about mass spec experiments where you
get a mass but you don't know what it is
and so we needed a way to be able to
incorporate these untargeted metabolites
now the traditional way of doing it is
to actually do very time-consuming
expensive steps to take some molecule
that you've detected as a mass and try
to figure out exactly what it is
so I'm inpatient so how are we gonna
handle the unknow metabolites well the
idea is we're actually pretty simple
we'll add a node to the network that
represents not the metabolite itself but
the mass will be detected in the mass
spec and we'll draw edges between that
mass node and the possible metabolites
that could be within the error range of
our instrument and now when we after we
saw I've solved the process collecting
Steiner forest approach some of those
nodes are going to be rather unconnected
some of them gonna be connected so that
allow us to throw out some possibilities
and then we do these robustness
calculations to see how often we get
nodes back and that allows us to give
increased confidence to some assignments
as opposed to others and just to give
you an example sheep like this
Huntington's disease where she had 38
untargeted metabolite Peaks for lipids
which could be associate with up to 300
was slightly more than 300 metabolites
and we also had 31 phosphotyrosine
changes and when you collect do the
price looking steiner forest approach in
each of these datatypes separately you
get almost no overlap but when you
combine them together you recapture
almost everything that you would have
captured with the data set separately
and a lot more so there was an example
of this where these are the mass nodes
these are potential assignments the size
indicates our confidence in the
assignment and we went back with a
different platform where we could
actually measure these specific lipids
and we're able to confirm that these
were actually changing we were able to
find some of these hidden nodes that
were not directly detected as masses but
we predicted were relevant that were
changing one of these actually is able
to change the viability of these cells
all right so I'm gonna try to wrap up
then and try to summarize the basic
approach this ol mystic integrator price
looking Steiner force uses this very
simple approach we just try to zoom in
on a piece of the interactively we
believe is most relevant to disease
process I haven't shown it to you here
but we have other papers we've shown
that it's can be done in a patient
specific way we believe that these are
fairly mechanistic models in that
they're based on physical interactions
but they're not mechanistic in the way
that say a true KEGG pathway would be
and so this gets the sort of a general
approach that we have which trying to
think about different kinds of modeling
approaches based on what kind of scale
they work on do they work on the genome
proteome scale or the only work on
systems of fairly small known components
and whether they use statistical
associations or physical associations
believe these interactive models live in
the upper right hand corner they're good
at the genome proteome on scale we can
stick in tens of thousands of nodes and
hundreds of thousands of interactions in
principle and get out something
interpretable but they're not predictive
in the same way that a differential
equation based model would be predictive
or say you know precise model of a
metabolic process and so our overall
approach that we're trying to work
towards is to start with all of our omec
data use these interactive models to
shrink down the problem and then to
answer your question then apply other
kinds of modeling techniques where we
can more accurately model the dynamics
of the logic of the system okay and so
with that I want to close I want to
thank some of my collaborators tried to
mention everybody in my lab who is
working on this as we spoke but we've
had a lot of help with the price of in
Steiner force from Ricardo Sakina at the
Polytechnic of turin and jennifer chasse
and christian Borges at the Microsoft
Research and without it be happy to take
your questions
yes
so we penalize the edges based on their
reliability so the interactome is coming
from many different sources some of them
are from very careful experiments done
by if somebody really passionately cared
whether protein a interacts with protein
V and others come from I don't make any
enemies but I wouldn't say he's too
hybrid or something right which is no
novel high false positive rate and so
you want to be able to to balance those
two you don't want yeast two-hybrid to
be considered as significant as
something that someone who's been
studying for a decade and so you can
think of if you knew probability that
the interaction was real you'd want to
basically sum up the the log of the
probability just take the product of all
the probabilities and some pathway right
and so the scores we have are no longer
truly probability when st was doing it
they actually were probabilities but
it's hard to do that in these mammalian
systems but they're they try to scale
them based on reliability and then force
the algorithms use more reliable edges
when it can so the issue is there are a
lot of false negatives in the
interactome and that's an unknown what
is the Rumsfeld's kind of known knowns
and unknowns and yeah
so we know they're unknown unknowns
right so we don't know how many of the
edges that are missing are missing
because just someone hasn't measured
them yet in this formalism well we have
done a little bit of us you can add
predictions right so kind of substrate
predictions are easy things to add
because we have some good idea of how to
do that in principle one could add
protein protein interactions from
predictions as well and you'd weight
those appropriately to be you know very
low confidence but possible to be there
so we need a lot more work as a field on
building up the interactive them I think
yes why degree why are penalties linear
for degree in proteins and quadratic for
metabolites ad hoc we're just trying to
to make sure that networks don't connect
all by you know that calcium isn't
connecting everything that water doesn't
connect all biological processes I mean
water does collect all biological
processes right but we don't want it to
be the short circuit and everything so
when we ran it with a linear degree in
in the metabolites because the well I
can't say why the because but
practically when we use a linear penalty
for metabolites we would get far too
many basically short circuits with very
generic molecules that we thought were
unlikely to be relevant to any disease
process and one way we can assess that
is with randomizations and so this isn't
all just eyeballing it but we'll take
input are real and potata and then we'll
do a degree matched selection of nodes
from the network that are simulated data
and we can run that many many times and
see how often we get certain nodes in
the random input versus the real input
and if when we use the linear degree
linear penalty we get a lot of these
very generic molecules that showed up
regardless of what the input was and
when we switch to a quadratic we got
fewer of those
workplace approach instead of the
questions time of course and and why did
you decide for the yes the question was
have we thought about using a diffusion
based approach so we started this
because we thought it was a framework
that we felt help we had ideas about how
to expand it to incorporate other kinds
of data like the negative data could one
get the same thing with diffusion I
suspect one could I mean a good
carpenter can build anything with a saw
and a hammer right so I don't know that
a bake-off between approaches is
necessarily all that useful I think if I
are an expert in diffusion based
approaches I could probably get to the
same results yeah I guess I can go
horizontally protein interaction but
someone might be passionately interested
because that's a really good question so
we haven't tried to systematically
remove all the literature based
interactions that would be an
interesting thing to do I can say we're
working across many different diseases
and the approaches seem to work in
better study diseases and less well
study diseases but that myself doesn't
answer your question so that might be
worth exploring on the other hand you're
probably removing from removing a lot of
you know of good signal to all right
it's yeah that's a that's a challenge to
think about yeah
upon is exactly two dollar water dish
that axis everything but no issue so you
can be protein-protein interactions or
plant in DNA interaction when we look at
those halves and practical valid in
famous have made now we understand is
able to modulate images so we have more
and more this example by way of an
important customer conservative them
ionic effect that will they complete the
level model but with some sort of global
variables incorporated not as part of
the network which is think about
right so the question was things like
water or calcium or Mick as a
transcriptional regulator really do
influence everything and so could one
have a modeling approach that deals with
that and maybe that gets to that slide
with different modeling approaches that
the goal the interactive is to shrink
your problem down identify relevant
molecules but it's not the endpoint
right we're going to need two other
kinds of modeling approaches and so
trying to figure out how say to put in
mix so it's regulating all transcripts I
think is something that one could
incorporate but it would be a different
modeling approach yes so the question
was do we have the same kinds of prizes
for different kinds of nodes so the
place that we've dealt with this
explicitly is the predicted
transcription factors which we wrote the
algorithm and so we have very little
confidence in it right so we don't
really believe all of our predictions
and transcription factors we don't want
them to dominate the network so we added
a variable to sort of tune down the
transcription factor prediction so there
prizes we try to do something at some
log of the probability we try not to
have the predicted transcription factors
dominate
so the transcription factors are
specifically down waiting in principle
the one might imagine the one needs to
tune other kinds of prizes because the
assays are not on the same scale so yeah
that's something we need to explore we
rely on other people's solutions that's
the short answer so there's it's an
np-hard problem there's an exact but
obviously very slow solution that's
based on into general in ear programming
that we started with that didn't scale
very well so Ricardo Ricardo ever he was
at Folly técnico developed probation
message-passing that's fast enough to
solve some of our real problems but
we're also talking some people who've
developed some heuristics to try to
shrink the part of the network than you
need to work on before you solve it so
that's not the part that we've done the
deep dive and we rely on others who are
more expert I think the next person
needs to talk right do you have this